they're tearing down statues of
Frederick Douglass critter Douglas Lee
black abolitionist they're tearing down
statues of Frederick Douglass
some were torn down in Rochester New
York local media reported now it's
unclear who did it was a black lives
matter who did it maybe was it aunt Eva
who did it
maybe if so it will be excused and
ignored if they find out that it was a
white right winger who did it then this
will be blasted over the news ad nauseam
and it will prove the double standard
right because you can tear down statues
of everybody it's fine it's a good thing
it's wonderful but you tear down a
statue of Frederick Douglass if it's if
it's a white white guy white nationalist
white supremacist who does it this will
be considered indicative of this long
historical trend in American history
either way though of course it shows the
absurdity of this and it shows this
historical battle there's a viral video
over the weekend from tick-tock of these
two girls talking about their view of
American history which i think has
become a common view among the youths
forget the enslaved to tide and built
this place for free so I proudly lived
up all the folks who are still oppressed
today because there ain't no doubt this
ain't our land
Trump in the USA - white liberal gals
that's the view that's the radical view
and it's the view that comes naturally
from liberalism because you've always
got to be you know even even the idea
that you're liberating yourself from the
oppression of say the British monarchy
or King George the 3rd taken to an
extreme that complete over into always
having to liberate yourself from the
oppressive past which means toppling
your own hero
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description